Allez qui ?
Vous avez des boulangeries qui ont été complètement bombardées
De plus, il s’agit de gaz, ce qui entraîne de nombreuses lésions cérébrales.
Il n'est présent dans aucun gaz ou gaz
Carburant anti-insectes
La première chose à faire, ce sont des cachettes. Il y a un grand nombre de personnes
Les personnes déplacées de Gaza et des régions orientales de
Rafah et de nombreux endroits viennent à nous, mais je ne le suis pas
Je suis capable de leur mettre beaucoup de pression de la part des gens
Les possibilités sont limitées
Très avec
Un certain nombre de personnes et demie attendent à la boulangerie
Montre-nous et vois, on prend ce qu'on prend, et c'est mon tour de
Cinq et demi
[musique]
Debout
Al-Tah
une